ブッダゴーサ長老はもうはっきりと五番目だけですよと書いてるんですね
ですから このタカハシさんがこれ大体あのブッダゴーサ長老の長老論から読んで作ってますので
そこはまあ彼の丸はテキスト通りなんです
で ですから そこら辺どう解説するかちょっとわからないんですね
で  第一禅定 識界で作る禅定を作れるならば
禅定っていうのは一 二
三 四まで順番で行かなくちゃいけないし
ですから途中で瞑想の対象を変えると
まあどうかなという問題があるんで
そういう実践のところはブッダゴーサ長老考えていないんです
だからって私にそれを批判する権利は全くないし
まあこれテーラワーダ仏教の権威
権威者でしたから 彼はもう第三番目のブッダみたいなものやとぐらい信仰されてましたよ
どこでも並の知識人でもなかったし
ですから まあ彼もやっぱりこのいろいろ伝統的なことやらアビダンマ的なことやらね
考えてそういう結論を出していると思います
そこら辺は説明できますけど
まああまりその初心的なアビダンマではそこは言ってもいいかどうかよくわからないんですね
うん まあブッダゴーサ長老はシャっていうのはこのジュの一つとして取ってるんですね
で だから瞑想すると この喜やら楽やらいろんなものが生まれてくるんだ
で 喜やら楽やら第一禅定で生まれてくる
第二禅定で生まれてくる
第三 四禅定まで生まれてくるもんなんですね
喜というものは順番がありますけど
喜が上か楽が次かよくわかりませんだけど
とにかく喜と楽と順番だったら
もう最初に喜が消えて楽だけ残って
第四禅定から第五禅定に進む場合は
楽という感覚も消えてシャーになるんだと
で それだったらシャということを瞑想するならば
第一 二 三 四 四は生まれるはずがないと
これはヴィパッサナーだからね
感情を通ってはね という風な計算だと思います
それであって また浄土論では
このどのように慈悲喜捨の瞑想をやるかということさえも明確に書いてないんですね
慈悲 メッターの瞑想はものすごい延々と長く長く書いてあって
慈悲喜捨になってくると
瞑想の実践的なやり方も書いてない
で そこは大体テキストにはまあ仏教は書かないし
まあそれぞれお坊さんたちのところで
先生のところで個人的に教えてもらうものだから
まあ浄土論は必ずしもそれは先生から教えてもらうようにということで止まっているんですね
で 私はこの慈悲喜捨の四つの瞑想は別々にインディペンデント
独立して瞑想をやる方法っていうのはね
一応頭の中にはありましたけどね
あまり誰にも言ってはないんですね
どこかに書いてでも置いておくかなと思ったんですけど
別にまあ後でその気持ちはなくなってしまったんです
で  そういうことで未定のままで終わりにしたいんです
なんだかんだ私は勝手に結論出しちゃうと皆様の仕事はなくなりますので
一応あの浄土論というテキストとアビダンマの世界では
慈悲喜捨の捨の瞑想は第五番目の禅定だと決めている
一 二 三 四は得られないと
そちらには私は色を持ってるだけなんですね
だから私の意見は皆様に言ってもそれほど意味がないし
それはまあそれなりの大物の先生たちに言わないと
こういうことですよと
どう思いますか まあ一旦そこを覚えておいてください
でも無色界の瞑想になると
それはもう無色界だから
どんな方法でも第五番目の禅定まで行って
そこから進むものなんですね
ですから 一つの道しかないんですね
無色界になると いろんな瞑想法から
いろんな道から第五番目のステージに行くと
行ったらそこからあるのは一つの道なんです
無色界の四つの瞑想 禅定は
ですから 無思惟界の四つの禅定はそれだけで独立してあって
他のことはちゃんと用意して順番でそこまで進んでいかないとできないものなんですね
でも 色界の瞑想っていうのは
一般的な人々が始まるものだから
何かの自分に気に入っている方法から始めて
禅定を作っていけばいいということなんです
ですから 私が言いたいのは
方法はどうであろうが
心は統一していくと 心が統一している過程が誰にでも同じですね
ですから それはお釈迦様がこの禅定で現れる現象ではなくて
禅定っていうのは心理学的に分析しておいたんですね
そこはまあ大体宗教の世界では大変嫌われるもの
現象かもしれませんだけど
一般的な人々はもう聞きたがるのは
なんとかヨーガの瞑想ではどういう風になりますかと
他のヨーガ方法ではどういう風になりますか
どちらの方が優れているんですかとかね
そういうふうなことは聞きたがるんですね
ですから いろんなヨーガシステムというのは
まあいろんな宗教にもありますし
ヒンドゥー世界でもたくさんヨーガシステムありますし
ヒンドゥーでないイスラム教にしたってもヨーガはあるんですね
ですから このイスラム教では何派でしたっけ？スンニ派？なんとかというね
宗派があります それでまた神様をね
念じるということを特別にやっていて
だからそこは一般的なコーランで言っているものじゃないんですね
修行しなさいということは
イスラム教では言ってないものなの
修行する必要ないんです
ただ 道徳的な決まりさえ守っていればいいんですね
別に道徳はないんですから
イスラムの聖書では いわゆる精神的な道徳っていうのはないんですけど
社会的な政治道徳ですか
そこは厳密に書いているんですね
離婚する場合はどれぐらい相手に払うべきかと
例えば毎月一パーセント
五パーセントか七パーセントかないで
自分の全財産から寄付しなくちゃいけないと
そうやってこの社会的な法律的なものは書いてありますからね
そこでイスラム法律というものも別に成り立っているわけです
精神的なことは書いてないんですね
そこは神を絶対的やつにして
そこは神を守るために頑張ればよろしいと
どんな方法でもいいというふうなことで終わってますね
それなのにまた他の宗派が出てきて
一生懸命修行するという人々もいるんですね
ですから このヨーガというのはイスラム教にさえもあります
当然ジャイナ教っていうのはもうはっきりした瞑想の宗教です
ですから瞑想っていうのは
どんな宗教の世界でも見られるものです
ですから この解決 宗教家ではなくて
このラショナルな人々
理性を持ってる人々には
科学的に物事を見ている人々にとっては解決さ-できないんですね
で 何かの修行をやって
何か神秘体験あるんだとする
また他の人も出てきて
具体的に言えば 例えばハレラーマの宗派の人々が音楽踊り事を踊ることによって神秘体験を得ているという
そこでマリア派のキリスト教の人々が
マリアを念じることによって
自分たちにはちゃんと神秘体験があるんだと
いろいろお告げがあるんだという
そこで独立して物事を科学的に客観的に見る人にとっては
どちらが正しいかと聞いたって
それは困ったもんなんですね
わからないんだよね どちらが正しいかと
で その自分の神秘体験というのは
あくまでもその主観的な体験で
その人の体験なんですね
ですから お釈迦様が取った立場というのは
その人々の中の頭を脳細胞を解剖してみましょうと
どんな宗教にも入らないで
この物事を喋っている人々の脳細胞は一応解剖して見てどうなっているんですか？そうすると科学的な結論が出てくるんですね
そこはもうきれいに科学的な方法なんですね
例えば海の中を見ると
全く植物に見えるものの生き物いるんですね
枝が出ていて 葉っぱがあって
でも植物ではありません
生き物なんです でもなんで見た目で植物なのに
なんで植物だと決めないかというと
やっぱり科学の世界は客観的に分析して解剖して
生物は生き物は何ですか
植物は何ですかと定義付けてるんですね
その定義から見れば このものにはやっぱり消化器官があったりして
餌を取って食べたりして繁殖したりするんだったら
たとえ形が緑色で枝がいっぱいあって
地面に海面に浮いていても動かないでしょうがないんです
それだけのことで 正真正銘の生き物ということになってしまっちゃうんですね
そういうふうなやり方なんですね
仏教のやり方は ですから
この瞑想の場合は いろんな人がいろんな神秘体験のことを語る
その神秘体験を語ったことで
どんな結果になるかというと
互いに喧嘩することになっちゃうんですね
私が正しいんだと その相手の方が
いえ 私が正しいんだと
だから結局心清らかにしようと思って瞑想していたところで
余計な高慢が後からついてくるんですね
自分が正しいと 最初はそう思わなかったかもしれません
自分がすごい神秘体験があって
大変ありがたい気持ちになりましたと
心清らかになりました
それはそれで構いません
だけど それから人間と付き合ったりすると
他の人と喋ったりすると
やっぱり新しくまた汚れが心に入ってしまっちゃうし
高慢になってしまったり
今までなかったぐらいのいろんな煩悩が生まれてきて
大変なことになってしまっちゃうんですね
そういうことを客観的に見ると綺麗に分析できるんですね
一つ言えるのは たとえ瞑想したっても
禅定やら神秘体験があったっても
安全じゃないということ
心は汚れるんだと 堕落するんだと
それはなぜ堕落するんだというと
やっぱり自分の意見を正当化しようと思っちゃうと
必ずしも自分の心はひび割れが入っちゃうんだと
いくら安定してあっても
それでお釈迦様の結論出すのは
最初から意見を持たない我見我見というか
見持たないように心を自由にしておけば
別に壊れることないだろうと
じゃあなんで見持ちますかというと
そこは心のちょっと問題ですよと
そこら辺は直して明確に心綺麗にしてみればどうですかと
綺麗にするということは
私が偉いんだというふためではなくて
心には何の意見もないんだと
そこでもある個人だから
その人には好き嫌いやら
自分個人としてのいろんな経験があるかもしれません
それは語るときも まあ私にはそういう経験はありましたけど
だからと言ってそれは世界的な正しい経験かというようなことはわかりませんと
で そこのっぽい立場 説明するためにあるエピソードがあるんですね
このエピソードっていうのは
サーリプッタというシャーリプトラというお釈迦様の一番目の弟子
智慧の第一人者 で そのサーリプッタ尊者がこのお釈迦様の次に仏教を理解しているんです
だから哲学的にはもう物事を理解しようと説明しようと
その人にはもう並べる人はいなかったし
そこでその尊者が自分で一人で考えて
世の中ではね お釈迦様ほど完璧な完全な智慧の完成者がいません
と言ったところで だから自分の考え方だからね
その言葉をお釈迦様にも言うんですね
ただ お釈迦様にはあなたは過去に現れた悟った人々の心を完全に自分の心でもって知り尽くしたんですか？で
そんなことはやってないんです
じゃあ私の後で現れる同じ真理を発見する人々の心の状況も
あなたは完全に知り尽くしていますか？そんなことを知りません
だったらなんであなたはこういうふうな言葉を言うんですか
ブッダより偉い人は世の中にいませんと
なんであんた言うんですか
それはあなたの信仰ですよ
あなたがそう信じているんだと
そこをはっきりしてほしいんだ
あなたの個人的な好みと知識的な言葉っていうのは明確に発揮して欲しかったんですね
だから現代にはいないんです
あれほどお釈迦様ほど厳密にこの知識人でインテリで
もう真理だけ みんなに語ろうというふうに努力できる人は
たとえ自分の第一番の弟子であろうとも
わずかな考え方の差でも
これを厳しく直しちゃうんですね
そこで彼の考え方はもう直してあげるんです
どういう風に直してあげるかというと
論理的に因果法則に基づいて考えると
悟るということは こういうこういうこういう過程ですと
生命には煩悩あるということは
こういうこういうこういうことですよ
その煩悩は何事もお釈迦様にはないんだと
それで過去であろうか
将来であろうか 生命が悟るということは
こういう風な この煩悩ですね
この貪瞋痴をなくして無明をなくすことによって悟るんだと
そういう論理に基づいて考えると
過去過去生でいくらブッダたちがいても
その方方はお釈迦様と同じですよと
これから将来で我々だっても
まあそれぐらいは最高なレベルですよと
そういうふうに言うべきですよ
だから悟りのことを明確に知っているサーリプッタ尊者特に因果法則の専門家でしたから
それ因果法則に基づいて明確に喋るべきでしたところで
すぐ 自分の好みを言ってしまったんですね
そこまでお釈迦様は厳密に訂正するのです
私は勝手に喋っているんだけど
言っていることは理解しているかいないかだったり
わかりませんだけど それでこの禅定についても
だから誰の瞑想が正しいか
誰の瞑想が間違っているかということは
この世の中の人々に興味あるかもしれませんだけど
仏教にとしてはそんな関係ないんです
興味ないんです 仏教という世界は科学的に心を解剖して見るだけ
それだったらもう人は白人であろうが黒人であろうが人間だから
心はみんなに同じはずなんですね
その環境によっていろいろ変化が起こるかもしれませんだけど
アフリカに住んでいるか
アメリカに住んでいるかということによって
でも科学的に見ると アフリカにいようがアメリカにいようが
嫌なものに出会ったら怒りが生まれるんだと
好きなものに出会ったら欲が生まれるんだと
そこは普遍的なんですね
それだけのことで普遍的なものがわかるんですね
アメリカの人が あの 何といいますか
あの サテライトからいろいろ管理して
どこかの国に爆弾を落として舞い上がって喜んでいるんだと
そこでアフリカの人が木に隠れて
いろいろな藪にちょっと隠れていて
弓で あるいは吹き矢で獲物を倒して
やったそうで喜んでいるんだと
そこら辺だから 何だと
あんなアフリカ人が関係ないんだと
というような馬鹿馬鹿らしいことであって
科学的に見るとどちらでも同じなんですね
心の心の状態から見ると
二人ともやったのは ただ環境違うんだから
アフリカの人が吹き矢でもうそこら辺にいた小さな動物を落としたかもしれませんし
こちらの環境違いますから
もうエアコンディショニングの部屋の中に塵一つも入らない部屋の中にいて
コンピューターのキーボードだけいじって
1万人の人を殺したかもしれませんし
でも敵を倒して ああやったぞと威張る心の感情と煩悩というものは
どちらの人間であっても同じことなんです
だから仏教はそういう風な目で物を見ているのであって
人を批判したり差別したりする世界ではないんですね
そこら辺は理解していただければね
大変ありがたいんですけど
そういうわけで 誰かの瞑想を論じてるわけではなくて
このアフリカとアメリカ人の例で考えてみてください
この頭の中の心を解剖して
こうやってアビダンマみたいな学問もできているし
そんなものお釈迦様の考え方から発展したもので
お釈迦様は禅定を説明する場合は明確に心の変化だけ書いているんですね
第二禅定生まれた人には
チンというか考え方 ヴィサッカがあって
ヴィチャーラがあるんだと
ジンとチという 2つが頭の中で物事を考えて対象をつかまって
つかまって つかまっているんだと
心の働きなんですね ほんのちょっとの努力があって
対象をつかまってるんですね
言葉かけて対象をつかまってるんです
そこでその人は大変喜びを感じている
ピーティですね 喜を感じて楽を感じているんだと
で スッカラ ものすごく落ち着いて楽しみも感じているんだと
それから心は統一しているんだと
だから心の中を見ると
言葉をもって対象を追っているかいないか
対象は何ですかと聞いてないんです
これは対象はバラモンですか
ブラフマンですか ジーザスですかと
それは関係ないんです
自分が瞑想する対象を頭の中の知識での働きによってつかまっているかいないか
本人が楽しみ 喜悦感を感じているかいないか
心は統一しているかいないか
その 5つの特色心に揃ったところで
それに第二禅定で読んであって
瞑想法は何でしたかということは仏教にはそれ興味ないんですね
それはもう科学的な世界でなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 病気になった人が病気は何ですかっていうことに興味あるんだけど
着ている服はどんな服ですかっていうことは関係ないんですね
だから本当は世の中の人々の探す
この偉そうに知識的に探しているような感じがするんだけど
結局患者さんの場合は
このあんたどんな病気ですか？あなたの病気ですか？ではなくて
服で決めるんですね あんたはすごいこの西洋風な新しい
一番新しい時代の服を着てくるんだから
第3番目の診察室に行ってくださいと
あんたはまあ伝統的な日本の服ですから
じゃあ5番目に行ってくださいというふうに患者さんを診察室に配るんだったら
それは科学的ですかね
でも この知識的にやってる人でやってるのはそういう仕事なんです
マリア様を信じているか
アッラ信じているか どちらかです
そこで喧嘩までしているんですね
そこは意味がないんだと
意味があるのは マリア様を信じてあんたどれぐらい人間になったかと
アッラさんを信じてあんたどれぐらい人間になったかという
たとえお釈迦様を信じたっても
人間になっていないならば無意味なんです
褒めるわけにはいきません
たとえ私はいくら出家であろうとも
キリスト教のある人が人と喋ってみるところ
その人がすごく心穏やかで
優しくて清らかで正直な人だったら
その人を褒めなくちゃいけないんです
あんたキリスト教だから認めませんと
そういうのは服で患者さんを選べることと同じことなんですね
正しくやるということは
患者さんが何着ていたってもどうでもいいんですね
その場合は それで あんた何で来たんですか？私はちょっと気管支が弱い
じゃああんたは5番の部屋に行ってくださいと
じゃああなたはなんで？私はちょっと血圧が高くて
じゃああんたは3番の部屋に行ってくださいというだけで 3
番目の部屋の血圧の患者さんが集まって
気管支の問題の人々は5番目の部屋に集まるというふうになってきて
そこでうまくいくんでしょう
だからこの世の中のやり方っていうのは
この口先だけですごい科学的やと言うんだけどね
本当はそうじゃないんですね
だから私たちはそうやって論理的に喋ると
すごく失礼じゃないか
乱暴じゃないかと 我々の文化に合わないんだとか
いろんなことを言うんですね
だからどう考えても これいくら日本の文化に合わなかったっても関係ないと
文化じゃないんだと 服じゃないんだと
文化っていうのは服だから
これは科学ですよと これはもう 1億回でも
今度何兆回言ったとしても
なかなか理解しないということもありますけどね
とにかくそういうことで
この禅定 というものには心の変化があって
その心の変化でラベリングするんです
第1か2か3か4か5かと
というような問題は ウペッカー瞑想によってなぜ第1 3 4
生まれないかということなんですけど
まあ私個人的な あくまでも個人的な意見なんですけど
もし人が最初からもうウペッカー瞑想を始めたならば
その人もそれによってどんどんどんどん心は統一するはずでしょうし
統一していくならばこの順番で行くでしょうし
いきなり番目に飛び出すことはできませんし
最初は大将を追っていかなくちゃいけないし
ですから第1から5までいける可能性もないわけじゃないんですね
それでブッダ長老はこのアビダンマでこの分析の問題もないわけはないんだから
分析の問題もありますから
このウペッカーということはウェーダナーの一種でとっているんだから
でも慈悲の瞑想の場合は
これウェーダナーの一種かないかっていうことも考えなくてはならないことで
それは皆様の仕事でも私の仕事でもなく
それは仏教の徒労の方々の仕事なんです
とにかくテキスト通りの勉強ですから
ウペッカー瞑想によって第五禅定ですよと
テーラワーダ伝統でははっきりと決めているんです
今日はページ のヴィパッサナー瞑想の世界なんです
で ヴィパッサナーの瞑想の場合は
この第一禅定 第二禅定
第五禅定とかね そうやっていうふうなステップではなくて
ヴィスッディという言葉で七つのステージを考えているんですね
だからヴィスッディはこの清浄ですね
まあヴィスッディっていうのはやっぱりこの洗濯ということで
心の洗濯なんですね 心は汚れていると
この汚れている心は七段階で洗濯して完全に綺麗にするということなんですね
その はっきりして心をきれいにするプロセスだから
そこを一つ二つ省いてみましょうということはできません
服の洗濯と同じなんですね
まあ一応ね 自動全自動洗濯機に服を入れたっても
その決まってる順番があるんですね
その順番でその仕事を行うんですね
でも手動にして自分でいくつか省いてもらうこともできます
脱水から始めましょうと
そういうプログラムをすれば
まず脱水と で それから水が入ってたところでソフナー入れて
それから一回二回ぐらい回して
また水を出してスピナーが回ると
それで洗ったことになりますか？ならないんですね
最初の工程三つぐらいもう置いているんだから
洗ってない服は今日時間ないんだから
まずこのスピナーで脱水のところでそれ回してもらって
それからじゃあアイロンかけましょうと
それで洗ったわけにはならないんですね
ですから省くことはできません
七段階にはあります で
うーん どうなってるんでしょうかね
とにかくアビダンマはずっと語ってきたのはこのこのところを説明するためなんです
ですから そこら辺は本当は明確に言わなくちゃいけないんですけど
この説明はこのアビダンマであろうとも
平等論であろうともかなり難しくて複雑ですけど
一応まず項目だけ出てくるんですね
ヴィスッディ・ナナスは 1番目はシーラ・ヴィスッディ
えーと 戒 戒清浄ということで
あの説明は後で来ますので
戒律によって心を清らかにする
2番目はチッタ・ヴィスッディという心の清浄ですね
で 次に心を清らかにすると
3番目はディッティ・ヴィスッディ
ディッティっていうのは人の見解なんですね
考え方 そこを洗ってもらうと
で 順番で言えば まず性格を洗ってもらって
人間として性格できてる人にする
それから心を洗ってもらって
心も清らかにした人になってもらう
それから考え方 意見 ちゃんと洗ってもらって
ちゃんとした哲学者にしてもらう
ちゃんとした科学者にしてもらうという
これも全部洗ってもらうんですね
もう汚れを 次にカンカー・ヴィターナ・ヴィスッディ
これは日本語でどのように
度儀ですか？度儀清浄ですか
度儀 度儀清浄 度儀というのは渡るということで
あの儀が渡るんだと いわゆる儀の段階を渡るんだと
たとえ頭を綺麗になっても
意見 哲学者として 事実は何ですかと
真理は何ですかという疑問的なレベルがあるんですね
その疑問的な疑い そうであろうと思いますけど
わかりませんと その人言ってることのそれなりの理由はあるんだけど
だからといってわからないというふうな状態
みんなの心にあるし 見を持ってる人はそうじゃないんですね
私はあの人言ってることを信じるんだと
事実であろうがなかろうが関係なくなっちゃう
そのレベルを乗り越えたら
あの度儀清浄のレベルになってなるんですね
それで あ 真理はこういうものやとはっきりしちゃうんですね
そこをいったところでマッガ・マッガニャーナ・ダッサーナ・ヴィスッディという道非道知見
それからまあ知恵なんですね
真理わかったところで知恵が現れて現れてくるのは当たり前なんですね
ただ わかったんだと もう疑いはないんだと
それから正しいものについて智慧が現れてくるんですね
最初に現れてくるのはマッガーマッガーという道と道でないもの
いわゆる心を清らかにするために
悟るために 真理を知るために
こういうやり方ですよと方法論が見つかるんですね
これはある程度で科学的に言ってるみたいなもんなんで
例えばある程度で基本的な研究をしたところで
我々が研究論文か研究なんかする場合は
まず基本的なスタディというレベルがあるんですね
いろんな本をテキストを読んでみたり
ディスカッションしてみたりして
いくらか頭にそのノウハウを叩き込む
それから自分で何でしたっけ
仮説作るんですね 仮説っていうのはいい加減に作ってはいけません
仮説を立てる場合は かなりの研究してないと
おそらくこれは正しいやという
おそらくではなくて もう間違いなく正しいだろうというところで仮説作るんですね
それからその仮説を なんて言いますか
成立するために自分で研究をやらなくちゃいけないんですね
そこが道なんですね こういうふうなこういうふうな研究をやっていきますよと
そこで研究研究方法はもう決めちゃうんですね
研究法を決めるのは仮説をできたところでなんですね
仮説をできるためには大変な勉強をまたしておかなくちゃいけないんです
そんな同じ順番なんですね
真理はこういうものだと分かったところで
じゃあそれ体験するためにどんな方法ですかと
この方法しかないんだと
マッガーマッガー道と道でないというところにその人は到達しちゃうんですね
次のはパティパダーニャーナダスティナヴィスッディ
行道智見清浄と書いてますね
道かどちらが道かどちらが道でないか分かって智慧が生まれた人が
次にその道を実践してみなくちゃいけない
自分決めた研究法で研究しなくちゃいけない
その研究をやってしまうということなんですね
決めた通りに パティパダーニャーナダスティナヴィスッディ
その研究をやった終わったところどうなるんですか？あの仮説は成立してしまっちゃうでしょうに
だからニャーナダスティナヴィスッディ
七番目 智慧が生まれてくる
すごいわかりやすい七段階だと思います
普通の世の中でどこにでもある研究たち研究する方法から考えちゃうと
誰でもそんな七つの段階でやってるんですね
そこで仏教だけ紹介しているこのヴィパッサナー瞑想の世界は
いかに一般的で科学的かということはわかるはずなんです
今まで説明したサマーディ世界っていうのは
それはやっぱり神秘の世界で
精神の世界で宗教の世界なんですね
瞑想するんだと お釈迦様の道になってくると
瞑想するんだといつの間にかっていうことではなくて
ものすごい厳密に科学者のやり方なんですね
そのところでの そこでそういう七段階目の清らかなレベルが生まれてくると
選択が選択するんだと心は
一番目はシーラヴィスッディ
生き方ですね だらしないような生き方で何のこともしない
できない それはもう基本的に誰でもわかります
勉強でも何もできない
生き方がだらしないんだったら
寝たい放題寝たり 遊びたい放題遊んだり
そうやっても行儀が良くない
わがままだったらもう何もできない
ですから まず生き方っていうのは
これは世の中どこでも同じことなんです
学校に入って勉強したければ
もういい加減好き勝手にだらしない生き方はできません
その人は自分のいろんな規則を守らなくちゃいけない
学校の規則いろいろありまして
それはちゃんと守らないと生徒にはまずならないんですね
生徒になっても卒業まではいけなくなっちゃう
それは基本的なんですね
一番目は それで例えば学校の例でいきましょう
学校に一応入ったとする
入ったらまず規則を守ることはもう入る瞬間で約束するんでしょう
上のコレジみたいだったらちゃんと自分でサインして契約書を交わさなくちゃいけないんですね
規則を守りますと 子供たちの学校の場合はね
契約交わすことはないんですけどね
でももしかすると親に契約を交わす場合もあります
日本はどういうふうにやっているかわかりませんだけど
やっぱりその学校によって厳しく親に契約交わせると
規則の契約なんですね
そういうそういうことを破ったらもう退学ですよ
だから子供にサインさせたっても意味がないんで
未成年者であって法律的には成り立たないんですね
だから保護者には未成年者に法律を守らせる権利が義務があると
そういうことで あの